not only is she beautiful and extremely
talented she's my little sister Jamie
Lynn Spears pretty but so proud
introducing Jamie Lynn and the Grand Ole
Opry in March once a promising child
star jamie-lynns career was derailed by
scandal when she got pregnant at just 16
years old
well our sobytia' Lacey visited the now
25 year old at home in Louisiana for an
ET exclusive as Jamie Lynn returns to
the spotlight on her own terms
tonight's big picture from Teen Mom 2
taking charge I'm gonna try to sing some
song for y'all that in the green bag
although just 25 years old a Jamie Lynn
Spears life is the stuff country music
is made of pain heartbreak and
ultimately redemption let's go back to
that moment what was your initial
reaction when you discovered you a
pregnant I would think it's exactly what
you would expect the cliche of oh my
gosh like what do I do
where do I even begin hey Zoe hi hey
James our decisions for any 16 year old
but when you're a teenage TV star even
more so I knew that the world was gonna
be watching and I found out I was
pregnant made a decision that I was
gonna go home I bought a house in the
middle of nowhere and I said I'm gonna
stay here was in the middle Mississippi
and I've got to grow up I've got to
figure out what kind of future I'm gonna
create for my daughter I mean I was
about to have a child it's 16 years old
and things weren't made any easier when
the paparazzi came to her small town the
hardest part was trying to figure out
why these grown men were following a
young girl around she's already going
through so much in the middle of nowhere
I mean they were pushing at that point I
can understand if I'm sitting in the
middle of LA you know it was just that
for me was the hardest part for the last
nine years jamie-lynn has done her best
to stay out of the spotlight and raise
her daughter Maddie who is now eight
you slag go today married to a 34 year
old husband also named Jamie she's
finally ready to resume her career and
the first step is a new TLC special
Jamie Lynn Spears when the lights go out
she hopes it will reintroduce her to the
world people met me as a young girl and
I needed something to bridge the gap for
the world to meet me as an adult
as a mother as a woman as a wife and who
I am right now in this present moment
Emily do you foresee yourself having
more kids of course my husband would
like kids like yesterday I think right
now that um it would maybe be a little
selfish of me to have a child right now
because I am getting busy but yeah we
want more babies of course and off her
older sister who also came through some
rough times any plans to work together
in the future in the studio I think that
it's one of the things that has to
happen naturally
you can't like plan it out say this is
what we're gonna do we're gonna sing the
song if it was something where we sat
down and we you know wrote something or
if there was a song I think oh we got to
sing this together but it's got to be a
natural thing it can't be forced
if you could go back is there anything
you would change now about the way you
grow up I would say the only thing that
I maybe would change is that I wish my
whole family could all still live in
Luisi that would be nice of like all of
our houses were like a block away from
each other that to me I think would be
probably the best thing in the hotel
room